STACY SCHIFF: Thanks so much.
Just after I started
work on this book,
I went to see one
of the greatest
scholars of the 17th century.
He'd written some of the
finest pages about Salem,
and I wanted some advice.
When I left him that
day-- we were standing
on the front porch
of his house--
he added another
little piece of advice,
pretty much as an afterthought.
He said, I should
probably warn you
that when you write
about witchcraft,
really strange
things happen to you.
And I kind of forgot about that.
The comment
disappeared in the air.
And I went on to
research the book.
I write the book.
I finished it more
or less on schedule,
kind of more or less maybe sort
of approximately on schedule.
The publisher was
really happy with it,
and they were even
happier when they learned
that Publisher's Weekly was
going to do a profile of me
this summer, with
which they would
run a full bleed,
full page picture.
And indeed they did.
And here's what it looked like.
So as you may notice,
that Stacy Schiff is not
I. Thanks to Twitter, it
took me about 90 seconds
to figure out that it's Amy
Stewart, a novelist whom
I've never met.
She does have a book out this
fall, which I'm thinking maybe
I could cross promote.
And when I asked my
publisher to send me
this page so I could show people
what strange things happen
to you when you
work on witchcraft,
I also asked them to send
me the table of contents.
And here it is.
I don't know if you can
read it, but essentially I
was rather surprised to
learn that after four
years in the archives
unearthing, and deciphering,
and squinting at documents,
corralling my imagination
and hiring fact checkers,
I had written a novel.
So strange things
obviously do happen to you
when you work on witchcraft.
This is not a book of fiction.
Instead, it's an
attempt to grapple
with exactly what happened
in eastern Massachusetts
in 1692, among the loopiest,
really certifiably strangest
moments in American history.
Salem may qualify as the best
known, least understood chapter
in our past, partly because
it seems so improbable
and partly because it comes
to us through Hawthorne
and through Arthur Miller who
were in fact writing fiction.
Here we are halfway between
Plymouth Rock and Paul Revere,
and suddenly everything
just goes screechingly
off the rails.
As I'll also make clear, in
the course of nine months,
we go from one kind of story to
a very different kind of story.
It's a tragedy to which
we go back regularly.
Few corners of American history
have been so often explored.
And if you don't believe
me, take a look at this.
Here's my local library's
stack of 17th century
American history.
So you can imagine me crawling
my way-- eating my way--
from one end to the other.
The other slide
is my office shelf
when I finished
writing the book.
You can see at the very
top there those little
Loeb Classical Library volumes.
Those were leftovers
from the Cleopatra years.
And I've always
wondered what Cicero
thought about being wedged
between the Puritans
on both sides of him there.
Salem is a little bit our
national campfire tale.
It's one of the rare
moments in our history
when the candles are
knocked out and everyone
seems to be groping
around in the dark.
That's where all
good stories begin.
In the dark, we
imagine most vividly,
and we believe most fervently.
It's in the dark that we
contemplate our mistakes
and wrestle with our fears.
"In the dark," goes
the Italian proverb,
"every cat is a leopard."
And if you read the court
papers of 17th century Essex
County, which I spent
a lot of time doing,
you begin to notice that
the New Englander lived
very much, very attentively,
and very apprehensively
in the dark.
Women tend to stumble
into their beds
to find strange
men sleeping there.
Men trip home through
the night to discover
that familiar landmarks have
moved and that people get
lost in their own backyards.
Young men report that they're
weak-kneed at the thought
of riding home in the night to
their families after sundown.
And when the devil
offers to accompany them,
they accept his offer.
I read every 17th century
account of the New England
murk, of the wolves
howling in the distance,
and the lurking
Native Americans.
But it took me a
really long time
to figure out how dark
dark truly could be.
And in truth, it
took me until this.
This is midtown
Manhattan in 2012
in the wake of Hurricane Sandy.
I was driving some friends
home to their home downtown.
We were uptown, and
we had electricity.
And suddenly, all those accounts
of the New England wilderness
made sense.
I mean, you couldn't
see anything.
You could truly become
disoriented in your own yard.
And hence, the line in
chapter one of the book,
"The sky over New England
was crow black, pitch black,
Bible black, so black
it could be difficult
at night to keep to the path,
so black that a line of trees
might freely migrate
to another location
or that you might find yourself
pursued after nightfall
by a rapid black hog
leaving you to crawl
home, bloody and
disoriented on all fours."
That's, by the way, from
the court testimony.
The basic facts of
Salem are simple.
In early 1692, over a
particularly cold winter,
a nine and an 11-year-old girl
begin to shudder and scream.
They happen to have been the
niece and daughter of the Salem
Village minister, Samuel Parris.
Here he is.
He would have been in
his late 30s at the time.
The cousins complained that
something bit and choked them.
Their bodies twisted.
They would attempt to
fly through the air
and climb down wells.
We have lots of descriptions
of the afflicted girls,
the bewitched girls' symptoms.
But we obviously have no image.
And here's the closest
that we can really come.
This is a 19th century French
text on the phases of hysteria,
on the emotional trauma and
what its physical manifestations
would have looked like.
Remember that no one
in the 17th century
distinguished between an
over-taxed nervous system
and bewitchment.
The first question
anyone asked in the face
of these kinds of symptoms was,
and for some time would remain,
am I bewitched?
It was understood that
any kind of prolonged fit
had been sent by the devil.
And indeed, within
a matter of weeks,
two other village girls began
to exhibit the same symptoms.
Everyone soon learned
from their parents,
or from local authorities,
or from Reverend Parris,
that they were bewitched.
And with that as the
diagnosis, you could very well
imagine what came next.
The girls' symptoms
seriously deteriorated.
Soon enough, all
four of them could
reveal who bewitched them.
We don't know why they
named the names they did.
But when you think about it
for a second, to the question,
who irritates, who annoys
you, who unsettles you,
who wishes you ill, every
one of us has an answer.
And so did the girls.
The answer to that
question in 1692 was clear.
It turned out that
there were not
one but three witches
flying around Salem.
Warrants went out at the end
of February for their arrests.
The suspects came immediately
before the authorities.
Justice was very swift
in the 17th century.
And they were
interrogated in the manner
of a day, which meant
that a local beggar
woman, the first
woman to be deposed,
was asked by the justices
when she had signed
a contract with the devil,
why she hurt the girls, what
creatures she had
dispatched to do so.
Those questions came to
her from very well-dressed
important men, who owned
significant businesses, who
spoke with weight and authority.
The contest was
asymmetric, and I
should say that
this is a story that
has something for everyone.
And here you can see it begins
to mutate because it begins
as a kind of fairy tale, "once
upon a time a wicked witch
cast a spell on a little girl,
and it turns very quickly
into a courtroom drama.
Let me talk for
just a few minutes
about how witchcraft worked,
what exactly a witch was.
Are not every 17th
century New Englander
was clear on the subject.
But those who were
were exceedingly clear.
To the early American, a
witch existed as plainly
as did heat or white.
The early American
witch, I should add,
did not look like this.
Although there is a
certain "Wizard of Oz"
theme running through
the Salem story,
and I'll talk about
that in a minute.
And nor did a 17th century
witch look like this.
This is, by the
way, the original--
if you can believe it--
the original Wicked
Witch of the West from the
book "The Wizard of Oz."
I particularly like
that flying pig tail
and the spats, which are kind
of unexpected for a witch.
This is an early
American Halloween witch.
You can see that witches
came very late to Halloween,
and they didn't
dress in basic black
until after Margaret Hamilton
and the 1939 "Wizard of Oz."
The witch as a 17th
century New Englander
knew her was someone who could
perform unnatural feats because
of the compact that she
had signed with the devil.
And from that pact,
she drew her power
to transform herself into
cats, wolves, rabbits,
and of course rapid black hogs.
A witch could be a man or woman,
but more often she was female.
And she maintained a
menagerie of imps or familiars
who could do her bidding.
And those mascots could
be turtles or weasels.
Cats, dogs, and toads
were very prevalent.
As you can see here, this
is a 17th century witch
who is feeding blood to
her diabolical toads.
This is a woman who has her
diabolical familiars with her.
You can see her black cat of
which there are a great number
and her demon familiar.
And she illustrates a 1621
English witchcraft case,
but this woman actually
was acquitted at her trial.
Here's some more
diabolical familiars.
You see that they range from
the standard issue barnyard pig
to rather gargoyle-like
fantastical creatures.
Black cats were
particular favorites.
They seem to have been
the arch enemy of man
from the very beginning.
And they turn up regularly
throughout the Salem testimony.
They've enjoyed an association
with the devil for a long time.
Black dogs turn up a lot
too, but historically
English witches intended to
prefer feline to canine form.
This, by the way, is
not a witch's familiar.
This is our family cat, Moose.
But I hope she's looking
sort of vaguely demonic here.
A witch signed her pact
with the devil in blood.
And she enchanted with
effigies and ointments.
She could be a muttering,
contentious malcontent
or she-- or he-- could be simply
strong or unaccountably smart.
Both kinds of witches
would turn up in 1692,
as would wealthy merchants who
were witches, sea captains who
were witches, ministers and
homeless five-year-old girls
who were witches.
While her power
was supernatural,
the witch's crime
was a religious one.
In New England, her target was
the soul rather than the body.
And our connection to
convulsing Salem girls?
According to the legal guide on
many Salem desks and which was
about to land on
Samuel Parris's desk--
this is the volume by William
Perkins-- "Witchcraft,
when it manifested, it showed
up the senseless trances,
paralyzed limbs, convulsions,
jaws clamped shut, frothing,
gnashing, and violent
shaking"-- In other words,
the symptoms of the girls
in the parsonage to a T.
When Massachusetts
established a legal code,
the first capital
crime was idolatry.
The second was witchcraft.
In the years since those
laws had been codified,
New England had indicted
about 100 witches,
a quarter of whom were men.
Massachusetts, however,
had hanged only six.
Beside the mystery of the
girls' symptoms in Salem
is a greater mystery--
why, in 1692, the hasty
and the merciless prosecution.
The charges were very familiar
from earlier witchcraft cases.
Casting spells on livestock
was a fairly common one.
In Salem, witches cast spells
on cattle, on hay, on wagons,
on muskets, on fireplaces.
They send dishes
sailing through the air.
Why, you might ask, are
these women riding on a pig?
This is from an early
English witchcraft trial.
These women have been accused
of bewitching the pig.
New England witches
do not do a great deal
of flying, down chimneys.
They do do a great deal
of flying down chimneys
and through apple trees.
And ultimately, they will
fly to a satanic Sabbath.
But I should say
that traditionally,
the English witch did not fly.
Continental witches,
however, will fly.
And that will give us
a clue as to what's
about to happen in Salem.
And also, there
were ghosts in 1692
who tend to flit in and
out of the Salem courtroom.
Most, but not all
of them, are women
who have come back to avenge
themselves on abusive husbands.
Those who do confess
to witchcraft--
and there are quite a
number-- will confess
to having flown either on the
devil's shoulders or on poles
or on branches or on sticks.
No New England witch ever flies
on a broom, I'm sorry to say.
These are some English flyers.
They seem to be recruiting
the women on the ground here.
This is an 18th century
woodcut, however.
As far as broomsticks go,
this one is my favorite.
Leave it to a French woman
to be able to fly gracefully.
This is a 15th century
French set of witches.
The accepted phenomenon
of witchcraft
basically went like this.
Witches existed everywhere in
the world in every culture.
And how is it possible
that imagination,
which is so varied
and so unpredictable,
could deliver the same
idea across all cultures
at all times?
In other words, witchcraft
was so preposterous, so
improbable, it had to be true.
You just couldn't
make this stuff up.
The first arrest in
Salem surprised nobody.
The suspects counted
among the likeliest people
to be voted off the island.
And let me talk just for a
minute about the next person
accused, the fourth accused
witch, for a few reasons.
I think part of what
fascinates us about 1692
is the random, the seeming
randomness, of the accusations.
What if the next knock
landed on your door?
In the case of Martha Corey, a
very pious, stiff spined farm
woman in her '60s, we
know what happened when
the knock landed on her door.
It was mid-afternoon
on March 12.
She'd been named by a
12-year-old village girl.
And it surprised everyone
because she was a full church
member and very devout.
Because she was, the church
deacon and another man
went to pay a call
as a courtesy on her.
And first they stopped off
to see the little girl who
had accused her.
They asked if she could
possibly be mistaken,
and could she describe what
Martha Corey had been wearing
when she afflicted this girl?
The child said she
couldn't because the witch
had blinded her that
morning, but she
would be back that evening
to torture her some more.
The men rode off.
They found Martha Corey
alone at her house.
She welcomed them with
a smile, but she also
anticipated their question.
"I know what you are
come for," she said.
"You are come to talk with
me about being a witch."
She was not a witch, and
she couldn't stop people
from gossiping.
How do we know all
this, by the way?
This is the deposition
against her,
which the two men will write
out after they visited her
that day.
And they tell her that
the girl has deemed her.
The first question
Martha Corey asks
is, but did she tell you
what clothes I have on?
They were flabbergasted
by that question,
because of course it
was precisely what they
had themselves asked.
And they seem to
think that she had
some supernatural knowledge.
She assured them there
was no cause for concern.
She had nothing to
do with witchcraft.
As everybody knew, she
was a very devout woman.
She wasn't surprised,
though, she said.
If the devil had
recruited the first three
women, in her
estimation, they were
malicious, slothful people.
An interesting thing
about Salem is that even
those who insist on
their innocence, who
believe in their
innocence, think
that the others are witches.
Martha Corey that
afternoon promised
she would open the eyes of the
magistrates and the ministers
so they might find the real
witches, another comment that
would backfire.
Within the week, not only
her 12-year-old accuser
but that girl's mother
was also afflicted.
A spectral Corey nearly tore
the older women to shreds,
offering her a
diabolical pact to sign.
The warrant for Martha Corey's
arrest went out immediately.
This is it.
She was accused of
having committed
sundry acts of witchcraft
on a grown woman
and on four youngsters, one
of the Reverend Parris's
12-year-old niece.
That note you can see in the
bottom in the different ink
is the Salem
constable's confirmation
that he's arrested her
and that she's in custody.
And this document
is dated March 21,
but because the Sabbath
was the next day,
she, in fact,
couldn't be arrested
until Monday, which left her
time on Sunday to go to church
along with her accusers.
So before the
pulpit that Sunday,
you have five spellbound
girls and women and one witch
suspect, all of them in close
proximity in a tiny building.
This is a reconstruction of
the village meeting house.
It measured 34 by 28 feet.
And you can see how dark
it would've been inside.
It wasn't always possible
during the hearings
that were held here to
identify suspects indoors.
They often had to be taken
out into the daylight.
And when the minister began
the service, the March service,
he was interrupted by the
afflicted girls in the pews.
One pointed to the ceiling.
She claimed she could see Martha
Corey sitting not in her seat
but up in the beams nursing
a diabolical canary.
The next day Martha Corey
returned to the same room
to defend yourself.
It was thronged with spectators.
There was a palpable
terror in the room.
A visiting minister said
that he could nearly make out
the hammering hearts, the raised
hairs on the backs of the neck.
Martha Corey insisted
on her innocence.
One of the justices
asked the question
that gnawed on every mind.
How had she known that she would
be asked about her clothing?
She tried to explain
but she was interrupted.
Generally, 17th
century courtrooms
were not orderly places.
The girls frantically
pointed about the room.
They could see they said
the devil whispering
in Martha Corey's ear.
"What did he say to
you?" asked the justice.
She had neither seen
nor heard a thing.
"We must not believe all that
these distracted children say,"
she replied, to which
they were fresh agonies.
"Did she understand the
meaning of distracted?"
asked the justice,
"because by definition,
distraction was fleeting and the
girls were utterly consistent.
Everyone," he reminded
her, "understood
them to be bewitched.
He urged her
repeatedly to confess.
She would not.
One of the interesting
things about Salem,
I should point out, is that
those who refuse to confess
will hang, which is to say that
the most principled, the most
noble, the most steadfast
people will end up
fairing the least well.
Corey was pelted with questions,
none of which she could answer.
Instead, she posed a
particularly plaintiff query
herself.
"Can an innocent person,"
she asked, be guilty?"
I don't know if you
can see it, but this is
the document of that hearing.
And the first question
here is, "You are now
in the hands of authority.
Tell me now why you
hurt these persons."
And she actually asks
if she can prayer.
She asks several
times, a request
which is repeatedly denied.
She insisted she
had nothing to do
with witchcraft, a statement
that incensed the crowd.
The girls began to yelp and to
snap and to mock her replies.
When she bit her lip
with nervousness,
teeth marks bloomed on
the arms of the girls.
If she clasps her
hands together,
the girls would
begin to shutter.
If she leaned forward, they
would crumple over in agony.
It seemed as if she
were working witchcraft
in the courtroom itself.
By this time, too, adult
women are bewitched.
In the course of the
testimony, one of them,
a 40-year-old woman,
starts to howl in pain.
And she says that it's Martha
Corey who's attacking her.
So the woman takes off
her muff from her hands
and throws it across
the courtroom at Corey.
It fails to hit here
so the women that
leans over and takes off
a shoe and lobs her shoe
at Martha Corey.
It hits her squarely
in the head.
A pin that she had stuck
in one of her victims
also turns up that day
in the hearing room.
Pins will tend to turn
up often in Salem.
Here are some pins, by the
way, from the Peabody Essex's
collection.
These were taken over the
next weeks or reportedly so
from the girls' hands and legs.
One girl turns up with a
pin puncturing her lips
so she can testify.
Blood will trickle from
another girl's mouth,
and a red stain will
appear across her bonnet
in the courtroom.
How do we know all of this?
From two sources.
A former village minister
was on hand that day
and published his account
of the trials in April.
This is the title page.
You can imagine that the
account of what was happening
did nothing to
alleviate the symptoms.
And we have a lot
of the paperwork,
too, from this
particular hearing.
This is the deposition of
one of Corey's accusers,
a 17-year-old girl
named Elizabeth Hubbard.
It seemed that Martha
Corey had urged her
to sign a pact with the devil.
She'd bitten and
choked and pinched her,
and the girl had the
bruises to prove it.
"I believe in my heart,"
she testifies here,
"that Martha Corey
is a dreadful witch."
And as you can see, some
of this was added later.
The court testimony's
interesting
because it's not
infrequently edited
or expanded on after the fact.
This is in the hand
of Reverend Parris.
It's the local
innkeeper's deposition
against Martha Corey
for having tortured
the girls at the hearing.
And you can see on that
second and third line,
he seems to have
written out the account
before he asked his neighbor
to fix his name to it
in the third line.
Martha Corey that
they went to jail.
She would spend the next six
months in chains and in prison,
awaiting her trail.
Six days after the
hearing, Parris
will deliver this sermon
in the meeting house.
You cal see it's titled "Christ
Knows How Many Devils There
Are."
And when I mentioned
documentation, by the way,
this is as good as it gets.
Parris was a very meticulous,
very diligent man.
And this is the finest of
17th century penmanship.
So I want you all to
feel sorry for me.
It's a finger-pointing sermon.
After this, it's basically
you're either with us
or you are against us.
And the community really divides
between accusers and accused.
People begin to remember
things that they
can't explain, often decades old
things that they can't explain.
Men begin to see their neighbors
flying through the streets.
The evening after the first
hearing, two villagers
will meet an unnatural
beast on the ground, which
dissolves in the moonlight.
Two or three women,
they testified,
materialized in its
place and fly away.
Shortly thereafter, behind
locked doors, one of them
sits up in bed when a great
gleam and a big fat cat
appears in his room.
If this has happened to any
of you recently, please let me
know afterwards.
All of this testimony
was sworn on oath.
It's all full of
tall tales unless you
happen to believe, as
one woman reported,
after having vowed to tell
the truth, the whole truth,
and nothing but
the truth, that she
flew on a stick with her
church deacon and two others
to a satanic baptism and
that the previous Monday
she carried her minister in
spectral form through the air
along with having previously
conferred in her orchard
with a satanic cat.
Again and again while
working on the book,
I kept thinking of Dumbledore in
the seventh Harry Potter book.
"Of course it's happening
inside your head, Harry.
But why on earth should that
mean that it's not real?"
The first case came
to trial in June,
the first suspect
hanged a week later,
protesting her
innocence to the end.
Events moved quickly.
Arrests and
afflictions multiplied.
It was a plague that involved
100 witches, a number that
grew to 307 or later to 500.
And here's where the courtroom
drama will mutate again
now into a horror story, not
only for those who spent months
roasting and then starving in
airless [INAUDIBLE] prisons.
Some suspects would die there.
And others, in chains,
would give birth there.
By late July, the
authorities begin
to piece together a tale of
a diabolical Sabbath which
witches flew to from as
far away as Connecticut
by various conveyances, all of
them to land in Salem Village,
and all of them
part of a conspiracy
not only to subvert the church
but to subvert the state.
And according to Parris's
daughter, by the way,
Martha Corey also will
attend that meeting.
Again, you can reconstruct
that meeting and these rituals
from at least 50
court confessions.
But we unfortunately
have no image
of the diabolical Sabbath.
Here's the closest we can come.
This is a 17th century German
engraving of a witch's Sabbath.
It's a more decadent production
than a New England one.
But certain themes are familiar.
You'll remember
that I said there
had been no flying in
Massachusetts before 1692.
Well, suddenly by the summer,
everyone in Essex County
seems to be aloft.
Here's an earlier illustration
from a Swedish witchcraft
epidemic.
And from the book,
you'll see why Sweden
is hugely important here.
But notice that this woman
is flying with her children.
In Massachusetts in 1692,
girls of eight or nine
are accusing their
mothers of coercing them
into signing pacts
with the devil.
By late summer,
the denunciations
are flying in every direction.
Daughters accuse mothers.
Brothers accuse sisters.
And parishioners will
accuse their ministers.
In Andover, nearly
one in 10 people
was accused, including
nearly every female member
of the town's senior minister.
Servants accused mistresses,
although mistresses did not
accuse servants.
No one ever suffered
from witchcraft
without also being
able to name a witch.
Martha Corey went to her
death in September 22
in what would be
the last hanging.
Before she hangs,
she's visited in prison
by Reverend Parris who
will excommunicate her.
And this is his account
of the excommunication.
He's irritated that
the prisoner, who's
a very religious woman,
refuses to pray with him.
In the 17th century, a
prisoner also, by the way,
paid for his or her jail
charges for the blankets
and the provisions.
This is the jailer's accounting.
And you can perhaps see
that the third item here
was for Martha Corey
and her husband.
By September, the colony had
executed 14 women, five men,
and two dogs for witchcraft.
Somewhere between 140
and 180 had been accused.
And then as abruptly
as it had begun,
the witch panic was over.
The questions the Salem elicits
are those of our nightmares.
"Can an innocent person,"
Martha Corey asked, "be guilty?"
"Might I be a witch
and not know it?"
another suspect
asked. "Could anyone,"
wondered a group of
men late in the summer,
"think himself safe?"
A brash widow in her 50s came
before the justices in April.
She was not a witch.
She could not even
say what a witch was.
She had the bad
luck to be appearing
before a fine logician.
"How can you know that
you are not a witch
and yet not know what a
witch is?" asked the justice.
So obviously, what
we have on our hands
is not entirely a fairy
tale or a courtroom drama
or a horror story
but a thriller.
Presumably, that line
of truths did not
move from one side of
the field to the other.
Presumably there were no flights
through the air, killer cats.
There was no satanic
celebration with a long banquet
table in the Salem meadow.
How, then, did
these things happen?
When you begin to pry
the whole episode apart,
you see that it makes uncanny
and eminently modern sense.
And no, I'm not going to tell
you how that came to pass.
The clues as to what
drives Salem forward
and what will result in an
unprecedented 100% conviction
rate for the only witchcraft
panic in our history,
are woven a strand at a time
into each chapter of the book.
And it's meant to
read like a thriller
so that you get the idea
that only at the end--
it's meant to unspool
with the logic of a dream
and the lucidity of
the supernatural.
The unlikeliest of heroes
will emerge in the end.
No, I'm not going to tell
you who they were either
because that would make
my publisher unhappy.
We go back to Salem again
and again for the same reason
that it came to pass
in the first place--
the irksome lack of closure.
We share the villagers'
need for resolution.
We go back to the trials for
another reason too though.
As crack ups go, this one counts
among the more sensational
in our history to which so
many later missteps would
be compared.
That is less on
account of the scale
than on account of
the circumstances.
The court in 1692 consisted
of the best and brightest.
They lived in the
finest homes in
their respective communities.
In 1692, it's the state
in the broad light
of day in the name of
God led by ablest men
in the colony who sent
innocents to their deaths.
When friends and acquaintances
came before them,
those authorities
doubted not the girls
but their own friends.
This is a portrait of
Chief Justice William
Stoughton who sat at the
head of the witchcraft court.
And I will give you
a hint and tell you
that he is not the
hero of the story.
He was nearly as starchy
as he looks here.
He's the most eminent New
England legal authority
at the time.
And he will die at home
nine years after the trials
without a word of
regret or apology.
He was the go-to person for all
legal matters in 17th century
Massachusetts.
No one was better
versed in legal code,
which points up something
else crucial about the panic.
Erudition plays much more
of a role in this story
than does ignorance.
Arguably, the Bay
Colony qualifies
as the best educated
community in history
of the world until that time.
The New England ministers--
here are Increase
and Cotton Mather,
the father and son
to whom any number
of civic authorities
would appeal for guidance--
had delved deeply
into the literature.
They have devoured libraries
on the subject of witchcraft.
If anything, they may
have read too much.
Today, of course,
the trials endures
as a sort of moral guardrail.
This is where Salem
mutates, yet again,
to become a cautionary tale.
They stop us when we over
react or over correct,
when fear tends to
overpower reason.
They make the experts
seem less expert.
They remind us of the risk of
thinking ourselves exceptional.
Satan's appearance
in Massachusetts
seemed to the New
England ministry
like a badge of
honor, further proof
that New Englanders
were the chosen people.
That statement resonates.
In troubled times, we naturally
look for terrorists and traders
and secret agents because
they hate us for our freedoms.
I just want to add
that Salem feels
deeply and eerily familiar
in an age of crowd sourced
stories as well.
An oral culture bears
a remarkable similarity
to an internet one.
Both feed on indelible rumor.
Neither has much use for truth.
And the internet turns
out to be a brilliant tool
for sowing conspiracy theory.
Things went viral in
the 17th century too,
and today, we can be two places
and two people at once as
well, just as Martha
Corey could simultaneously
be at home minding your
own business and at
the parsonage pummeling
and choking the children.
At Salem's heart, there's
a sort of fairytale
or are these rippling
sexual undercurrents
and a lot of terror.
It's really about what we
see when we close our eyes
and about how those images
can turn from one thing
into another.
It touches on what's unreal
but by no means untrue.
If we're all concerned, it's a
story about everyone's agendas
and everyone's secret
agendas-- the girls,
the justices, the ministers.
Everyone's trying to
accomplish something here
which is not what he
states as his goal.
They would truly unsettle
us, those agendas,
just as they unsettled
the 17th century New
Englander who met with the
goblin or the rabid pig.
And out of reasons,
the early American
turned to witchcraft
for an explanation.
Out of reasons,
you of course are
supposed to turn to a book,
which I hope you'll enjoy.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm told you may have
questions or comments
or corrections for me.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name's Laura.
I had seen something
once, PBS maybe--
I can't remember where--
talking about one
of the theories for what
happened in Salem being not
just the hysteria of the girls
but also potentially a fungus
that may have affected
them mentally.
I'm curious as to what
your thoughts are on that.
STACY SCHIFF: I
love that theory.
There's a theory that the
rye supply had been poisoned
and that a fungus that caused
hallucinations had grown.
And it was a great
and incredibly elegant
theory, which has been largely
discredited for two or three
reasons, the two foremost
ones being that the girls are
strangely, terribly
afflicted at some times
and perfectly normal
at other times.
And they tend to be
the convenient times,
like when they're
asked to do housework
or when they need
to testify in court.
And at other times, they
seem to sleep like babies
and be perfectly normal.
So that doesn't
entirely hold up.
Also, if the grain supply had
in some way been contaminated,
certain members of the
household-- everyone
would have been affected.
In this case, like
Parris's family,
there were three
unaffected children
and then there are two girls
who were convulsing, one of whom
is then sent away.
But it doesn't affect the
household universally.
And also apparently it was the
wrong season for such a fungus
to have grown.
But I love that theory because
it would have been so neat.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
I have a couple questions,
and you can actually refer me
to the book if that's better.
But first, what became
of the girls who were
the original accusers here?
And second of all,
historically, how much
time did it pass before people
properly came around on this
and said, you know,
the witchcraft stuff
is something in our imagination.
How long before that was
generally accepted in society?
STACY SCHIFF: They're
two great questions.
Let me start with
the second one.
What's really interesting
about the end of the trials
is that the accepted
wisdom seems
to be that they have
indeed murdered innocents,
but they also let
guilty people go free.
In other words, the belief
in witchcraft survived 1692.
The belief in a perfect
prosecution does not.
So the impatience
here is with the way
this has been prosecuted.
It's not with the
concept of witchcraft.
It will take years still
for everyone to give up
the belief in witchcraft.
In 1693, Cotton Mather, bless
his well-documented heart,
is taking clinical notes on two
more witchcraft cases, two more
girls who-- in
Boston-- are basically
experiencing the same symptoms.
And he knows enough in
1693 to take those notes
and to document
the cases, but he
says it's too volatile for him
to publish these things now
because everyone's still so--
because Salem and Andover had
been such a terrific wipe out.
And there's so much puddling
guilt and shame over the issue.
Nobody will talk about
Salem for quite a while.
But that belief in
witchcraft persists.
The girls themselves,
it's a difficult book
to write because, of course, no
17th century girl kept a diary.
So we have the
girls' voices in how
they converse with
the devil, which
is an interesting place
where they express themselves
the best.
The devil will
bargain with them,
and they'll speak
back to the devil.
Those accounts, of
course, come to us
from the male reporters
in the courtroom.
So we have nothing
that's actually
written in the girls' own
hand except some testimony.
We have no diaries.
And we have very little
about what happens to them
after 1692.
One of them apparently
does continue
to be in some way infirm.
And it's very unspecific about
what continues to torment her.
The others go on to lead
perfectly normal lives.
And as I think I say
in the last chapter,
they go on to get married
and have families, not
necessarily in that order.
There's a strange amount of
having children out of wedlock
among the cohort of girls who
had been afflicted in 1692.
But most of them do seem to
go on to lead normal lives.
It's interesting
because there had
been the case of possession of
serious diabolical possession
20 years before Salem.
And that girl who was
then a grown woman
would've been alive at
the time of the trials
and the mother of
a large family.
And I always
wondered, what did she
think of what was happening?
Because it could so easily
have happened in her case years
earlier, but the minister who
had dealt with her affliction
had really been very
careful about containing
the crisis in that case.
AUDIENCE: Can you
talk a little bit
about the research, how long
it took and where you did it,
and just what the
process was like?
STACY SCHIFF: It took
approximately 120 years.
The research took three
years completely--
it took me about three years
to research entirely and then
a year and a half to write,
during which I was still
researching a little bit.
Because, of course,
once you start writing,
you realize that you forgot
to research something,
or that you need to
know more or you just
haven't got to the
bottom of something,
or you're just
obsessive and you need
to keep researching because it's
better than writing, always.
So it breaks down
about that way.
The trial documents,
these illegible
beauties that you
saw, are most of them
at the Peabody Essex in Salem.
It's just astonishing.
You're holding these
papers that say
so and so has been maliciously
and feloniously and wickedly
practicing witchcraft
and is sentenced to hang.
I mean, they send
chills down the spine.
They have a great collection.
Danvers has a
terrific collection
because they have the
church record, which
speaking to holes in
the narrative, leap
frogs over the entire summer,
as does a lot of documentation.
There are huge holes
in the documentation,
so great was the regret and
the shame in the wake of Salem.
The Massachusetts Historical
Society has terrific stuff,
so does is it the New
England Historic Genealogical
or Genealogical Historic--
whatever it's called--
has great contextual stuff.
And the American
Antiquarian Society
has a lot of the
Mather material.
And essentially what
I filled in with
were other 17th century diaries.
And the quarterly court records
of the years proceeding Salem,
which are brilliant in giving
you a sense of what New England
life was like, what people's
grudges and antipathies were,
who was suing-- everyone, by
the way, is suing everybody.
This is the most litigious
society you can imagine.
And we're talking
about litigation
that can last decades and
slights that reappear years
later.
And it just gives
you such a sense
of what people's obsessions
were, what the hot spots were--
the trespass, and
drunkenness, and fornication
were the big sellers.
There are a number of witchcraft
accusations that go nowhere.
It's fascinating in
terms of giving you
a flavor of New England
life, which obviously came
in handy when you're
trying to explain
the strains on either a young
girl or a civil authority
in terms of adjudicating
something like this.
AUDIENCE: Another question.
So I think one of the
most frustrating aspects
of this story is this
concept that there's no way
to really prove your innocence.
I was curious if there's--
if it's a spoiler,
you don't have to share, but if
there's any record of someone
actually rationalizing their
way out of being accused outside
of just being executed
or confessing or pointing
the finger at somebody else?
STACY SCHIFF: You put
your finger, I think,
on the thing that kept
me awake most nights,
which is that you're in a locked
room and you can't get out.
And once you're accused,
basically-- the answer is no.
Once accused, nobody manages
to shirk the accusation.
There are two ways out.
One-- class plays a
huge role in this story.
The wealthy manage to escape.
And most of them will
escape to New York.
The relations between
Massachusetts and New
York at this point
are very hostile,
and New York very
happily takes them in.
And I kept thinking
there were going
to be great papers
in New York saying,
all those crazy
Puritans, look what
they're doing to each other.
I never found them.
But most of the fortunate people
who escape do go to New York.
And the other way to get
out of it was to confess.
Without spoiling
anything, it does
have some bearing on why
you have these unbelievably
specific and
colorful confessions
because the more you confessed,
the happier the justices were,
the more useful you
were to the prosecution,
the better you fleshed
out this crazy story.
And the confessors go back to
prison, but no confessor hangs.
So after a certain
point, it does
become clear that it's better
to accuse than to be accused.
And it's best to confess.
AUDIENCE: THey've told me
in Old Sturbridge Village
that there weren't
forests for the most part.
Everything had been clear
cut to be used for buildings
and heating and such.
What was it like
around the setting,
150 or whatever years earlier?
Was it foresty?
Because all the public
media presentations of I
thought I saw
something, hey, where
did that person come from,
are in a forested sort
of environment.
Particularly when you
have a low light, when
you have shadowy
light, it becomes
very easy to imagine things.
The demons in your
mind, basically,
become more tangible.
Was it like that then?
STACY SCHIFF: That's
also a great question.
And here's where the
court papers came in handy
and as did some of the
captivity narratives, which
there are quite a few.
Very unforested.
There had been a remarkable--
basically the Puritans arrived
and cut down all the trees,
is the long and short of it.
Sounds familiar, right?
And today it's much greener
and lusher in Essex County
than it would have been then.
And I kept having to remind
myself of that with the help
the Danvers historian
Richard Trask,
because I would say, well, you
can't see from this household
to the parsonage.
And he would say, but
you could have in 1692.
These trees are 100 years old.
And you can see in the court
records how much obsession
there was with timber.
Because, of course, without
timber, they can't build.
And without wood, they
can't heat their homes.
And again, without
spoiling anything,
the Parris household
is in particular danger
that winter because it's
up to the parishioners
to bring their
minister firewood,
and they don't like him and
they're not bringing him wood.
And it's a very cold
winter, and he's shivering,
and he's talking about
this from the pulpit.
And he's basically saying,
how can you leave me?
Without wood, I can't pray.
Without pray, I can't live.
You will dispatch me
to the other world,
and you'll have this
on your consciences.
It's a pretty
contentious relationship.
So yes, the wood is
a huge flashpoint
as is the trespass on
other people's yards
to cut down wood that maybe
isn't yours or the carting away
of other people's homes that
you could use for the wood.
And there was a second
part of your question?
Oh, you hear a lot about
swamps, what I was going to say.
When you read the
captivity narratives
and when you read about
spectral presences,
at this moment in
Gloucester, there
are a lot of sightings of a
spectral band of Frenchmen
and Indians.
And the local
militias is terrified
because they can hear these men.
They see these men, but
they can't find these men.
And they're clearly
just seeing things,
but they always arise
from the swamps.
There's a lot of talk about the
swampiness of the landscape,
very little about the trees.
AUDIENCE: Thanks, this
has been fascinating.
I'm looking forward
to reading your book.
And I was just curious,
do you have any thoughts
yet on the topic
of your next book,
if you're willing to share?
STACY SCHIFF: I
was hoping you all
were going to bring that to me.
I thought that was
the transaction here.
No, it's interesting.
This material, it does get
under the skin in a way,
and I have not entirely
been able to emerge from it.
I keep seeing angles
that I wish I could
play with a little bit more.
And I'm not sure if that's
the fault of the material
or of the tired and
downtrodden author.
But at the moment, no.
AUDIENCE: It's sounding like
the possible explanation of sort
of a combination of
external stresses
and internal just
quarrelsomeness
that seemed to exist is
maybe a good candidate
for explaining all this.
But I'm wondering,
and you've talked
about some of the possible
external stresses,
I'm just wondering
have people been
able to develop any personal
motives in any of this?
In other words, did
some of the accusers
have grudges or particular
quarrels or property issues
or anything like that
against the people
that they were accusing?
I think in your
book, I think you
say there was a lot
of just-- even people
within their same family
accusing each other, which
would argue against that.
But I'm sure people
have done-- probably
you have done--
investigation about just
the more obvious motives
that might have existed.
And what's the story on that?
STACY SCHIFF: There was a
wonderful book, some of you
may know, which essentially
argued that the whole thing had
been a property scam.
And if you accused
the right person,
your estate would
therefore flourish.
And it had a
wonderful set of maps
which proved that
the accusers were
on one side of town
and the accused
on the other side of town
and how all of the properties
had joined.
That, too, unfortunately
doesn't really hold up.
And it also doesn't
explain why you
have the intrafamily
accusations or why
someone like
Rebecca Nurse, who's
this extremely pious older
woman, who's actually
never been in court, which was
unusual in New England, gets
accused.
It's possible people thought
the family had too much land.
It's possible because
all her children lived
and most people lost children.
It's possible that the family
was simply too functional
and other people were jealous.
We just do not know
in so many cases
why the fingers pointed
where they pointed.
The property thing,
the only person
who makes that well in terms
of confiscating properties
is the local sheriff, who's
an extremely tireless figure
and manages to be
confiscating things
the minute anyone
is put in prison.
But he seems to have done it in
a somewhat under the radar way,
and he doesn't share his
proceeds with the authorities.
So it doesn't really
hold up in terms
of some kind of
conspiracy in that way.
To my mind, it's a number
of forces come together.
And I guess the one
that I would talk about
without it being a spoiler alert
is the political scene, which
is that this is a colony
that for three years
has been living
without government,
has a new government in place.
The strains of the
chaos of the last years
are still very apparent,
and the importance
of establishing rule of law
in the summer of 1692 is huge.
So for these men,
for the justices,
all of whom have helped to
topple a royal governor three
years earlier, and are
in disfavor in London,
to prove that they are competent
and law abiding and law
enforcing officials plays
an enormous role here.
AUDIENCE: I'm just curious
like your research process,
like the start to finish
if you could maybe touch on
like the first thing you do
when you're starting to research
a book or how that sort
of evolves as you're
further into researching
the book and stuff.
STACY SCHIFF: I'm really
unscientific, which is to say,
if I'm working on a biography,
which until now I had--
or a living person--
I usually started
with interviews because I knew
I had a limited amount of time
often with a
particular demographic.
Obviously with the book like
"Cleopatra," that didn't apply.
So I tend to go first to
the primary materials, which
is possibly the wrong thing
to do because you're coming
to them without the context,
and then I circle back to them
in the end.
So I went immediately
to the Peabody Essex
and read through the
witchcraft testimony.
I didn't know what
to make of some of it
because I hadn't read
everything else yet.
I tend to confine myself
to primary materials
wherever possible because
there's just such-- I mean,
you saw those shelves.
You could be reading in
those shelves for 15 years
and never get to the end.
So my feeling is to use
the secondary materials
as little as possible, things
like the Puritan Sermons,
any 17th century diary I
could get my hands on-- I
mean, I don't think
there's one that I missed.
Anything that a 17th
century New Englander
would have known or
read and anything he
wrote I needed to read.
And I don't do that in a
particularly scientific way,
partly because you don't really
know what you're looking for.
You haven't articulated
your questions yet.
And that ultimately,
of course, means
that I end up going back
to some of those things
once or twice again.
And the court testimony is
a perfect example of this.
I read it once in the original.
Most of it is published.
90% of it is
published, at least.
I went back to it again
in its published form
over and over again.
And then often, not
until two years later
did I actually notice that in a
particular person's testimony,
she doesn't really give
the authorities what
they're looking for.
She's just agreeing with
them and collaborating
with whatever-- and agreeing
with whatever they've said.
She's not adding anything
to their questions.
It's the kind of thing
that doesn't jump out
at you till you've
read it several times.
And so I guess the answer
to your question is,
it's a kind of full
immersion process for me.
But it doesn't necessarily
follow a linear line.
And with people like
Stoughton or the Mathers,
I can't read everything--
no one can read everything
that Mathers wrote.
So I would read
secondary sources.
And I would confine myself.
So that's actually a
frustration with somebody
like Cotton Mather who writes
I think 92 books in the 1690s
alone.
You have to really
limit yourself
in terms of what
you're going to read.
And those texts
are really crucial
because you begin to compare
different accounts he gives
or how he accounts for
witchcraft at different moments
and how his thinking evolves.
So I tend to go back to the
same things over and over
and read them more closely
rather than necessarily
spreading myself more broadly.
Thank you all.
[APPLAUSE]